be good give me a tylenol for that
[Music]
you're going to just happened
oh no
oh no
what did you
do it wasn't me oh but it wasn't
was it consho
who did you had
that's the third one there's a turtle in
there is this jake jake you're a bad boy
jake
what
[Music]
the earth must be spinning right
real fast no there's no day to night
this there's no day to night
like for you to go back in time i think
they're going back in time are they dh
in the universe
this is insane
i have so many questions about what is
happening right now
oh my god ah
welcome back to new rock stars moon
knight episode 3 takes a page from
raiders of the lost ark as kanchu
rewinds all of outer spaces episode i
guess killing any astronauts that might
have been in orbit or dh in the benjamin
button style and not to mention d.h thor
the guardians nick fury with those
skrulls looking for his shoes on the
space station
but uh really well we'll talk about that
i think really it was the subtle moment
earlier in the episode that we're
curious about a third alter hiding
inside of mark that we have not yet met
who might be the most murderous of the
three god guys
dang like he killed all the both those
guys quickly this is inside marvel it's
new rockstar's moon night after show i'm
eric boss i'm here with mt and hey yes
this is fun this week mt is gonna take a
turn at doing the easter egg breakdown i
cannot wait to see what is coming later
today empty anything you can tease for
us about what might be coming in the
breakdown well you know we're definitely
going to be talking about that huge uh
time travel moment where we got to
discuss what the heck that's even about
but uh yeah no it's gonna we're gonna be
talking about some some god stuff some
some uh um you know just uh finding out
who this hot tour woman is and you know
oh yeah you'll see you'll see it's gonna
yeah put in the hot and hot tour am i
right what have they gotten into
oh that that rabbit poncho that rascal
khan
i mean look at him he's hot i mean some
of those uh the scars in his skull were
just claw marks because you know right
we know this guy likes to uh strap
himself down in his bed layla jumped to
that conclusion i think we can write
some conclusions last night yeah
anyway uh in this episode it opens with
layla catching up with an old forger
friend of her dad's uh interesting
conversation happening there as you know
they're just casually stamping some
passports here
activities exist i mean can i just go to
these places that i don't have to go to
the dmv to get id's i mean it's not that
i want to be
anything bad about it i just this she
was in and out she got some marshmallows
like that's ex that seemed like a like a
pseudo-therapy session great
yeah uh interesting there character not
even named according to the credits it
just said forger like this person seemed
to have some kind of relationship yeah
maybe we'll meet her again maybe not um
anyway uh so she follows mark to egypt
where he's in the midst of pursuing some
local guys in search of harrow uh harrah
meanwhile like bellock and razor's lost
ark has used that compass to find the
buried who shopti of vomit is apparently
paid for his whole london cult to
caravan out to egypt to get digging i
mean between the alps and london egypt
the mileage they are racking up i hope
they got a sky mile planned because
man they are all of them together you
know some people were like um i just
like lived in london and like gardening
lentils do i have to go out in the
desert sun
like if you love ahmed yes you will poor
jamila is out there like all i know to
do is kick a soccer ball around and
speak really bad mandarin do i have to
do
[Laughter]
yo that man was good too not great uh i
love sh you see uh cheese tweets uh see
me lucas tweet about the mandarin that's
very funny no what did you say
he was like um arthur harrow definitely
needs a new mandarin teacher
yeah i think maybe
so as arthur and steven debate over how
violent to get with these guys mark gets
knocked in the head and has this
interesting moment where he falls back
in two different directions flashes
blacks out
and then comes to having stabbed them on
a rooftop now mark
did not do this steven did not do this
so who did
probably jake maybe another one of you
find out
but uh the last thug reveals himself as
an ahmet worshipper kills himself to
keep mark from finding harrow so
conscious to force an audience with any
ad but you know just creating a solar
eclipse no big deal casual
an ex-boyfriend trying to get someone's
attention like i will rearrange the
stars
so that you text me back
i will move the moon
you want the moon
i'll get you in the moon
freak out everybody every astronomer who
has had lunar and solar eclipses
predicted out like literal clockwork
like the the that was supposed to happen
for another three and a half years
it's
like we're talking about moving the moon
moving the moon you know global tides
are all screwed up countries are flooded
you joked about visiting the maldives
earlier they're gone they're gone you
move the moon
uh but hey this is also we're talking
about the indian ocean i mean a giant
celestial corpses in that indian ocean
cracked over the earth's core smashed
through the ozone layer in the
stratosphere which would have
devastating geological impact
gravitational effects tidal effects so
none of the physics of this world make
any sense
from the get-go
um anyway so uh by doing this mark is
summoned via this diagon alley style
portal uh into
the uh
inside the great pyradic giza that's
what's inside it folks it's not just
that little girl's gum it's uh the
cruelest courtroom that we've ever seen
um right because we meet the other
members of the ine ad where
interestingly we only need five of them
via their avatar
uh the female used to have a
relationship with khan shu got some
music uh and then horus and isis tefnut
and osiris interesting we didn't see all
nine though maybe they just needed five
of the nine for a quorum or maybe four
of the others really pissed them off in
the past or maybe this is just what the
conservative majority of the supreme
court does to really write all their
opinions and then you know the other uh
three i guess at this point liberal
justices are like do we even matter at
this point all these things
members of the supreme court are
appointed by conservative presidents how
dare you remind us of that reality i'm
not subscribing
that's not good
the people who claim to be our fans on
the new rockstars subreddit that's my
impression of them
you're best done nixon
nixon's ghost
has like a bunch of different burner
accounts on reddit and claims to be a
dozen different people
um it's the head the floating head of
nixon from a future
yeah oh no that guy would be awesome
like
i i'd
pay to have him be our family um instead
but uh anyway so yeah this is
interesting we just had a small group of
the net but also kind of makes us doubt
their legitimacy like you don't even
have all nine here uh seriously we don't
we don't interfere with the with mankind
you know we just kind of like puppet
their their flesh around like halloween
costumes but otherwise we don't
intervene it's totally fine and like how
how omniscient are these people because
they clearly can't see harrow they need
these human beings to see through them
so like it's just weird that like they
just can't prove a clear crime clear
crime is being committed by this man in
public anyway um and uh they uh well in
addition to having there were definitely
plenty of other ushabti's on the sides
as as mark walked in so it's like how
many gods have they just gotten pissed
off at and turned into
over the time that they did they did to
on it and at the end of the episode they
do the khan shoot like how many gods if
they're just like
shut up
so uh i love this scene though konshu
possesses mark's body oscar isaac again
making a great acting choices where he
screams his conscious at the indiana
they bring in harrow to face the
accusations but harrow goes dirty and he
uses mark's dissociative identity
disorder and one of the cruelest ad
hominem attacks i've ever seen in a
trial like how do these wise judges let
that slide like i get that uh judge you
know in a courtroom might dismiss an
unreliable witness at a trial but really
that's for the jury to decide but
there's no jury here it's just the
judges but they they would still look at
the other obvious evidence of the
accused wrongdoings right you still at
least listen like well you may be not
the best testimony but there is other
evidence we could look at that this guy
is trying to unearth a banished god who
has turned into a new shopkeep like
there's nobody empty
why did nobody go visit the tube it's
like hey are you gonna try to go visit
the tomb let's go see if he's right
let's go to them they could just get
like they could pull it up on satellite
imagery or just get a telescope and be
like oh his crew is out there in the
middle of the desert digging up but they
then again they did not know in fairness
to them they did not know where who
shopped he was buried but which is also
true
not a great plan can't they have a
middleman who's just this hey we don't
know where it is but you know where it
is is is someone digging out there and
it could be like oh yeah yeah that weird
uh david kresh guy his people are out
there digging they'd be like oh [ __ ]
that's not very good that's not good
statue uh but they didn't do that
no no
no
[Music]
anyway
i'm so mad that they pulled this eternal
uh you know cheat of like we're just not
gonna enter
stop changing the sky
ridiculous
statue um so anyway harrow walks free
which is crazy uh but hot to her credit
just take pity on mark and tell them
about this map hidden a sarcophagus
where they can track the burial place of
ahmed sushapti great plan indiana just
put it in a in a sarcophagus that can
just be traded around on the black
market and match report that's a safe
bet that's where you should hide your
internet passwords
uh all right
um so mark and layla actually head to
this home of anton mogart uh now in the
comics antoine mogart it's midnight man
here he is played by the late gaspard
julio that's the french actor who
tragically passed away after shooting
the series but before it came out uh
very very sad and he received a
dedication in the credits um very nice
i'm glad that they kept his character in
in the story um it seems like there may
have been more to his character in the
way that he leaves the series that they
may have edited around or cut out uh
it's a little awkward i thought this
whole subplot of the episode was just a
little awkward to sit through yeah
despite the action being great uh it's
just a set piece just felt a little
uncomfortable how did you feel about it
mt
yeah it definitely felt like there was
supposed to be more there um like that
there was they teased some type of
relationship between um
mogart and layla
and i just feel like he was supposed to
play a bigger role because like you said
he is the midnight man in the comics he
is this um
he's in he's in moon knight's rogues
gallery and uh you know arthur herrera
does end up visiting him and it seems
like harrow and him were supposed to
have some type of
meeting or connection that um he was
supposed to maybe help him but like he
ends up you know sort of riding off into
the mist at the end of the episode there
after being stabbed um so yeah i feel
like there was definitely a more of a
role that probably was removed because
of his um untimely death which is yeah
and i think they did the best with it
that they could but i think from a
writing standpoint this is just
something that like uh despite what
would happen to uh to gaspar julio
that's i think there just is like a
conception issue with all these series
where they they keep introducing
characters who are
uh antagonists from the comics but just
kind of the lower stakes the lower tier
antagonists and they don't really write
those characters well like we had um in
hawkeye we had kazi you know like qazi
was such an underwritten weirdly edited
character in hawkeye i thought like the
way zemo was using falcon winter soldier
just a bit disappointing by the end of
that scene like he just kind of ended up
back in prison despite you know i love
the characters zemo i love the actor but
like just the way they're used
throughout the series and then of course
the flag smasher carly morgenthau in
that show was just like weird like a lot
of like they don't really seem like
well-positioned characters uh like why
would you even bring them into the
series like what were your plans with
them anyway i know there's some
defenders who are like how dare you
speak i'm not i'm not i think the actors
was great and i'm glad that they kept
them in the show i just think this is
just a weird thing that all the disney
plush shows keep doing like they just
keep bringing in other characters as
like maybe red herrings uh but don't end
up really mattering at the end of the
episode it's more of an accusation the
past disney plus shows than in this one
but this is just this is what you get
with the after shows it's eric working
through this stuff my opinions aren't
always going to be ironclad and perfect
we don't really edit this i don't script
any of this it's just me this is how i'm
stewing through my feelings after an
episode comes out yeah man we're just
talking about it we're just we're just
expressing
it doesn't matter until it's too late
they're just going to
encapsule this
and they're going to throw it at me a
couple months from now
everybody be nice
it's not twitter's job to be nice
they're all just mad about elon and and
that's just it's just twitter it's just
an angry angry corner so but we do learn
about uh mogart how he's a collector and
a
fanatic of a medieval jousting i thought
it was interesting to watch all this and
i i yeah i got to learn about him as a
collector and that he spent time with
layla in medrapore
suggesting that like sharon carter
mogart acquired these antiquities in the
black market this way um which is just
interesting that we got a shout out to
madrapor now mark and steven analyze the
sarcophagus begin to fold the star map
like a mad magazine until harrow shows
up offering the scarab and then uses the
staff to smash the sarcophagus and shred
the star map like a brat taking his
kickball and going home so no one else
can play so the shootout breaks out mark
and steven take some hits he's seeing
those jousting poles going yes
dude he can take some wolverine type
punishment but the armor gives some
healing powers as conscious said earlier
episode so he's right like wolverine
like you know he's fine um but uh so
they're able to get away but layla asks
mark about something that she heard hero
say about mark being involved with the
death of her father and we learned that
she's got a dad and her dad was one of
those archaeologists and it confirms our
thinking last week that layla is likely
the show's version of marlene from the
comics maybe even harrow could have been
part of that backstory like what raul
bushman did in that
comic backstory um right so they end up
driving out to the desert they use
steven to reassemble the star map he
tapes it into a perfect star like
american chavez's perfect star pretty
damn good
was that originally how the map was
going to be folded like a perfect uh you
know i think that's how the way that
senpu designed it which is weird
genius interesting that they would do
that um
now but since the stars have drifted
over two thousand years conscious and
stephen have to rewind the entire
universe
back to the stars
when the map was created and laila is
able to use that to locate where amits
who shopped he's buried but uh by
messing with the astrology again that
anyhow that's one thing you can't do
don't mess with the sky
you're not confused people
geez they're real they're like the
people who go out into the field at
night and they have their telescopes and
they have their wine and their cheese
and then he ruined it by doing that it
freaked them all out
so they turned konchu into a stone
ushabti harrow coldly taunts kind of a
cool ending to the episode but i think
empty we got to talk about this
character we did not see this episode
perhaps the additional altar known as
jake lockley and why he might be the
most brutal of the three that we've met
so far before we get into that we want
to thank uh everyone who has bought one
of these uh moon knight tomb of the moon
god shirts thank you selling out pretty
fast uh it's a great shirt uh this
directly supports what we do here new
rock stories and when you get one of
these at newrockstarsmerch.com
you'll also unlock the ability to buy a
custom shout out that runs during the
bottom of the screen during these inside
marvel after shows so allison says could
ahmet be eliath with kang being one of
her avatars
oh
interesting thought
well based on what kang said
he said that he weapon or he remains
said that he weaponized uh
like the incursion energy of uh yeah
universal war into a light but i think
that it could be an interesting parallel
like definitely an analog in the way
that like eliath and kang had its
connection but it seemed like kang was
controlling goliath whereas amit is
controlling hero you know so it's
it doesn't really seem like but you know
ahmed is supposed to be the beast it's
not supposed to be like a deity it is
supposed to be like a beast that devours
the souls of the unworthy
so this is true i don't know who knows i
feel like ahmed is more of like a more
of a human sentience type of person like
a someone that can talk to you whereas
elias seemed like a i'm a beast i'm a
monster so i don't know if that's the
case but it would be really interesting
i would love that twist
daniel says with gore going around
killing gods does this mean kanchu is in
danger and if he dies what happens to
mark
daniel you are asking the right question
i'm telling you we're doing a lot of
videos about this coming soon especially
if we get a 411 thunder trailer next
week yes i think that's why all the gods
are being introduced on this show in a
multiverse of madness uh in thor eleven
thunder there's there in an eternals
like i think the this phase of marvel
supernatural is setting up gore to have
people to kill uh and i think you're 100
right i think kanshu is gonna be one of
the targets the whole aniad uh yeah
maybe that's why there's three empty
seats who knows maybe
omt with a hot take
yes
yes
great point empty maybe that's what
happened to them uh we'll talk about
that a lot more in the future now elac
says do the hieroglyphics on the tomb of
the moon god shirt have a hidden message
you know
you're gonna have to do some translation
and see if there is i think there might
be
and uh if you tweet at us in tag epic
hero shop
we'll let you know if you're right you
might get a little special shout out if
you uh
correctly find a hidden message in there
you tell us you tell us yeah all right
mt what's our first question this week
all right eric what the fish happened
when mark and steven blacked out like
who was the third alter ego that killed
both of those guys yes and uh and just
so clear empty and i week after week are
going to try to get better and better
about using the correct dissociative
identity terms um
according to dissociative identity the
clinical understanding is they
the preferred term is alter uh i know we
have used identity alter ego personality
and really we've just been following the
pace set by the show even in this
episode they refer to it as personality
and and other like promos they've used
the term personality and identity um so
uh yes but we're gonna try to use the
term alter just so like because the
correct understanding is that alters
within a dissociative identity uh
disorder person a person suffering from
that these are fully formed people that
are inside of them these are not just
like
personalities that they're trying on for
an afternoon these are separate memories
separate habits separate mannerisms uh
separate
separate histories you know like they're
different selves so everything that we
associate with someone's sense of self
that is what an altar is which is why i
i allowed that uh conversation in the
video that we released earlier this week
about this possibility that stephen
grant could have been an alter that was
targeted by the soul stone during thanos
snap i know i know our thumbnail on our
packaging upset a lot of you online but
just i encourage you to watch the video
if you haven't already because we're
we're really just extrapolating based
off fan speculation and we're trying to
be as respectful as we can and if you do
actually look at the clinical
understanding of dissociative identity
disorder
that
does suggest
that as much as we can identify someone
having a soul and what that means uh if
the mcu says that mark specter and
stephen grant are separate souls then
that's enough i i know there's there's
certainly arguments to be made that like
stephen grant doesn't consume the amount
of resources that thanos wants but i
don't thanos's snap was ever explicitly
that sophisticated i think he just
wanted to
snap away all intelligent life uh and
the soul stone was the mechanism through
which he did that so that's all we're
doing that's what we're doing uh in that
video i understand the thumbnail might
have pissed you off but i i can't
control uh how pissed off random people
on twitter just naturally react to a
thumbnail of a video and draw the
conclusions of it especially if you're
tweeted by a certain section of twitter
right now it's just getting mad at
everyone talking about moon knight uh
and matt at the show for
uh but i just encourage everyone please
do uh the research into what
dissociative identity disorder is before
deciding that anyone who uses the term
did is immediately wrong because you
decided that they're wrong
maybe you don't know a whole lot about
uh did as much as you think anyway my
rant is over um
so uh the moon night comics before mark
spector's condition was ever reframed as
as dissociative identity disorder back
in the 70s and 80s where they're just
like this guy's crazy because that's
what
comics used to just do
uh yeah there was a third alter
yeah a lot less sophisticated uh there
was a third alter that some that he
sometimes appeared as named jake lockley
who was a new york cab driver uh but
ever since the first episode we've been
wondering who exactly
might have asked out stephen's tour
guide co-worker dylan because mark
probably would not have set up that date
if he planned to travel to the alps that
weekend and dylan probably would have
noticed mark's american accent changing
to steven's british accent oscar isaac
confirmed this week that there are more
than two altars within this character uh
and in this episode
someone other than mark or steven killed
those guys on the roof and i think this
is proof that there must be a third in a
very dark altar hidden from us right now
someone we're gonna meet soon and i
think that third alter might be jake
lockley just because it's the most
known other name um here but i think
jake might not be the same cab driver
character from the comics but the way
that they changed stephen grant i think
someone uh
it may take a different form maybe
someone more brutal than the mercenary
mark specter because mark seemed pretty
freaked out in that moment and uh now
we're also extrapolating backwards
someone who's creeping on dylan suddenly
i'm a lot more worried for that tour
guide
what this person's intentions might have
been for dylan on that friday night
could we be looking at like a serial
killer a jack though that would be bad
kay
would plunge in a knife in someone's gut
more than a mercenary would be okay with
that um and empty i'm gonna ask could
that have been the altar yo imagine a
whole moon night season where like he is
his own villain that would be insane or
he has to fight himself anyway sorry uh
but yeah no i definitely feel like it
was it was dylan for sure that um
this sorry continue um but i'm gonna ask
him t could that have been the altar who
killed the archaeologist group that
included laylah's father and that's why
mark
feels his kind of mixed responsibility
for it but was okay marrying her like if
it was mark who killed them even if it
wasn't all him like maybe he was
alongside frenchie to comp following
harrow's orders when hero was possessed
by consho leading that but i i just
don't think mark would allow himself to
marry one of his victim's daughters uh
which was laila in this case uh mark is
certainly deceitful he's a man of
secrets but he's not that cruel he's not
sadistic especially when he wants to
protect layla from konchu and from
himself so i think mark may have started
a relationship with layla before that
ever happened or maybe after but either
way without knowing what his third altar
did or would do to her father and then
he discovered later
and that might have been the trigger
that led him to ghost layla and to step
away from her
because in this episode layla says i
wish you had told me more but mark may
have figured out like oh my god one of
my alters killed her dad i can't look at
her in the face right now i have to
protect her now at this point that would
be wild if that were the case it would
be vir it would be kind of a very
kind a sensitive thing to do but
especially before mark were to like you
know come come into contact with
whatever caused this weird conscious
stuff to happen because like i'm sure
disney wouldn't want to be like all
right
some people's did alters are crazy and
like they're they're serial killers and
like i'm sure that like they probably
wouldn't want to go that route
um but it is an interesting idea to
explore um if he does have a more
violent altar um and that's just like
more ready to scrap like a more like
street savvy like you know what like i'm
i'm from the streets because we know
that um jake lockley is this cab driver
character who's just like more street
savvy street smart type of dude so like
i'm imagining just jake lockley just
being like all right i'm uh i'm not like
i'm ready to stab whoever like i'm i'm
down like i'm from the streets like this
is what i do i'm from new york you know
what i'm saying like this is what we do
yeah so it's not like a premeditating
murderous person but he is someone who's
willing to cross that line i like that
approach i agree with you yeah i look i
we're kind of getting into
we're getting into a territory now where
like
it's getting hard to talk about this
show
because i think there's going to be a
contingent of people who feel that any
fictional creative license taking
exploration of dissociative identity
disorder that at all presents it as
exciting or action-packed or fun or
brutal or violent or scary if it's done
for entertainment there's going to be
some people who are just going to want
to cancel this series and cancel anyone
who talks about it in a positive light
yeah
it's so tough ultimately i still enjoy
the series i enjoy what it's doing we
have to let people just like enjoy
what's good about it and not get mad at
them for just talking about it this is
something that like people got mad at us
when we talked about falcon winter
soldiers just because falcon winter
soldier wanted to address the the
challenging subject of civil rights in
america and just because we pointed out
what they were talking about and we
wanted to join that conversation there
was a lot of people were like no no you
can't talk about this you can't talk
about this yeah superheroes i i i
definitely don't agree that but people
shouldn't be able to talk about d.i.d
especially since did
is such a big part of this show and like
people have to remember that we are in a
science fiction universe and so that
tries to
really try to replicate our universe but
these are sci-fi elements being
introduced with real world elements like
did so if did is a big part of this show
and we have these mysterious sci-fi
elements it's hard to not discuss those
two in the same type of way if we are
supposed to speculate what's going to
happen in the future of this this did
centric show so like we are
doing our especially with eric like we
are all doing our best to educate
ourselves on what the idea is so that we
can
very tactfully um try to you know
speculate on what's going on in this
very heavy mystic sci-fi world and um
and i think you know marvel studios has
that big
task here to try to walk that line as
well he does maybe and who knows maybe
we'll see at the end of the series maybe
marvel studios was not as ready as they
thought they were to have that
conversation right now i think they're
being respectful enough i think the fact
that like there's a lot of people
especially a lot of people on twitter
who are perfectly willing to let uh the
perfect be the enemy of the good
uh and they will constantly move the
goal post on what perfect is when we're
talking about these things i think at
the end of the day the the more we talk
about
mental health disorders and the fact
that a lot of people maybe not a lot of
people are going through dissociative
vitamin d disorder but a lot of people
are going through anxiety and depression
and things like alcoholism and does that
mean we can't talk about these things
just because it's something that people
are suffering with like
to me that tells me that you are not
someone who's ever actively sat in on a
in a counseling session or a therapy
session if you think that humor
is not a way that people deal with these
things if you think that people don't
make jokes who are suffering from
depression and can't joke about it with
their therapist or with their friends
like then
you're someone who to you this is like
an academic hypothetical thing and i
don't care what your opinion is about it
on twitter because
you're just someone who's trying to
cancel other people for talking about it
and you don't want to allow the
conversation to happen
um
i'm sorry you you're not in a position
to weigh in on these things
it's twitter bro
i can't stand it
i mean you're going to do it anyway i
don't really i mean i understand that
this conversation is going to happen um
but like i think we all need to just be
grown-ups about this and understand that
there is no perfect way to have this
conversation but the conversation needs
to happen uh and for sure we have to
allow ourselves to be creative and
explore it in interesting ways because
there's now there's gonna be all kinds
of people who never really thought about
dissociative identity disorder or mental
health struggles who now have an access
point into it
and yes that can feel like childish like
using uh toys to explain these things
but uh folks
using there is such thing called play
therapy and sandbox therapy where people
who don't know how to use words and
complicated terms to talk about what
they're going through are encouraged to
use toys in sandboxes to create worlds
and use that to tell their story that's
a completely valid way to express what
someone's inner world is going through
and for have to have other people
connect with it so to say that you can't
do the same thing with creating
a marvel disney plus series to do that
and to allow young people people of all
ages to connect with these ideas and
these concepts is such an absurd thing
to deny that experimentation from even
happening from the get-go oh yeah and
like you know
in like no for sure and i feel like the
the way that the mcu is going forward
like we're going to be exploring more of
these like mental type of like illnesses
because like with wanda like the wand
division was this huge exploration into
grief and depression that you know
this is a sci-fi version of it where the
chaos energy within wanda amplified her
emotions so like we are seeing a
physical representation of what
depression looks like what grief looks
like and that's what what makes marvel
studios amazing is that we can explore
those deeper things and like those more
complex and the diverse aspects of our
reality in this huge creative way that's
amazing and awesome so like what this
moonlight journey is though it's not a
100 um
like 100 accurate representation of what
d.i.d is because like no one's gonna
become a crime fighter with did like
it's obviously like heightened but like
we are learning like i love that i'm
learning more about the ideas as a as an
illness because of this show and like
that's what we have that's why we have
these amazing shows and so
to begin with
there we go yeah you have to allow a
freedom to fail you have to allow a
freedom to get things wrong uh just to
stumble through things because that's
you have to walk before you can run uh
and if we just wait until we stay silent
until we come up with like the perfect
way to talk about things no one's ever
going to say anything or talk about
anything exactly
and we'll just stay silent and alone for
our entire lives until things just get
worse and worse
that's not how the world works welcome
to the world the world is not twitter um
and twitter will never solve your
problems so anyway uh we talked we got
deep here empty this was an interesting
conversation yeah we skewed into the
type of conversation that terrifies me
here at new rockstars that i'm probably
gonna regret next week uh in weeks to
come uh because youtube is uh youtube
and twitter are no place to have a
nuanced conversation
um
i guess we'll uh those chickens will
hatch in the future over and over and
over again uh and people will never let
me forget it but there's a bigger nwtf
moment from this episode that we got to
talk about like what exactly happened to
planet earth in the final minutes of
this yes
we'll talk about that um but before we
get into that we want to thank some
friends who helped us make this episode
thank you to stance for sponsoring this
episode we love us some stance socks
around the office they fit great and
they have cool designs made with brands
like the wu-tang clan pixar the simpsons
they have a new line inspired by
guardians of the galaxy that looks
especially cool get some groot on your
foot
foot foot foot
foot
they're branching out beyond socks to
bring color comfort and creativity from
toe to head with the launch of some new
active apparel line check out stance's
super soft line of sweatpants shirts
hoodies hats and more now available in a
full range of fits prints and fabrics
and fun embrace a life of superior
comfort and creative expression with
everyday active apparel that truly is
stitched different stance's philosophy
is that you should never have to
sacrifice your own individual style for
the sake of comfort and now you don't
have to whether you're relaxing around
the house working out at the gym running
all over town stance now delivers its
signature softness and creativity and a
full line of active apparel styles from
toe to head stance has got you covered
head on over to stance.com and get 15
off your first purchase use a promo code
marvel at checkout to apply enjoy the
color and comfort of a life less
ordinary with stance stitched different
we also want to thank bluetooth for
sponsoring this episode we're pretty
confident in our theories here on inside
marvel
but confidence can take you pretty far
in life and in the bedroom and that's
where blue chew comes in blue chew is a
unique online service that delivers the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis but showable tablets in a
fraction of the cost you can plan ahead
or be ready for whatever an opportunity
arises the process is simple you just
sign up at bluetooth.com consult with
one of their licensed medical providers
once you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days it's all done
online so no visits to the doctor's
office no awkward conversations no
waiting in line at the pharmacy
bluetooth tablets are made in the usa
and prepared and shipped direct to your
door in a discreet package so if you
could benefit from some extra confidence
when it's time to perform bluetooth can
help and we've got a special deal for
our listeners try bluetooth free when
you use our promo code marvel at
checkout just pay the five dollars in
shipping that's bluetooth.com promo code
marvel to receive your first month free
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information and we
thank bluetooth for sponsoring the show
and lastly we want to thank helix for
sponsoring this episode so you've got
your bedroom set up just the way you
like it your ring of sand on the floor
your tape on the door your leg shackle
on the bed post but uh do you have a
good mattress that's a question well our
friends at helix mattress are here to
make sure you do helix sleep has a quiz
that matches your body type in your
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you they have soft medium
and firm mattresses mattresses great for
cooling you down if you sleep hot even a
helix plus mattress for plus size
sleepers i have a helix mattress i love
it mt you got a helix mattress you love
it
i love it so much my helix plus badgers
are the best what's the best well the
mattress ships right to your door for
free no need to go to a mattress store
you just go to helix sleep.com inside
marvel take their two minute sleep quiz
and they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life they have a 10 year
warranty and you get to try it out for
100 nights risk-free they'll even pick
it up for you if you don't love it but
you're going to love it so helix is
offering up to 200 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners at helix sleep dot com slash
inside marvel all right mt i want to ask
you what the fish
did conscious do exactly when he rewound
the stars i know you're gonna go into
this in another video but can you give
us like a preview of what what you're
thinking right now well um so of course
in this episode we learned from um
yatseel who was hattor's avatar that
senpu
buried a map to amit's tomb and when
they find that map they were like all
right this is a map that needs the sky
but the sky is different from when it
was 2000 years ago the earth drifted
like stars have gone out like
stars have died so like in order for the
for them to see the space how it was 2
000 years ago they would have to go back
in time so in order for them to do that
they would have to manipulate the
gravity of around earth because gravity
has a very unique relationship with
space time because like for example the
more gravity there is the slower time
goes around that place with more gravity
so
since the moon has a unique relationship
with gravity to earth i'm thinking that
whatever khanshu is
he is i think conscious itself he's just
gravity because like whenever um harrow
um said something like that pissed him
off he would shake things or like he
could only make the wind move um and
like i think that kanchu himself is has
the control and the ability to
manipulate gravity which is why he was
able to move that moon into a solar
eclipse before so what we're seeing here
is the moon that which is the purple
ring around the planet just
going around the earth a bunch of times
allowing the our planet to go back in
time like doctor strange in episode four
of what if when he used the time stone
to make
everything around him go back in time
except for his clothes and himself so
like that's essentially what happened
here which means
a plethora of things like if the
universe is 2000 years younger then that
means asgard is no longer destroyed you
know you've got you have a living planet
still out there being a jerk
all these huge things that could happen
to the mcu this is as big as the snap in
my opinion but yeah that's
this is i mean
if you were right on this you're right
this is as big as a snap in some ways
bigger than the snap i i'm gonna wait
and see
what exactly their the show says this
was before i jumped to conclusions but i
like where you're thinking i can't wait
to see your video on this i but i think
like there's a couple other
possibilities other than right actually
rewinding time like first off we got to
acknowledge so much of what we're seeing
in the show
just really could be illusions within
steven or mark's perspective
like all of this could just be a sort of
dream or some kind of distortion of
reality um so it's all from an
unreliable narrator so i think it's very
possible however
um i think it is possible that in this
moment like
it not necessarily it's an illusion
because i don't think that indiana would
be so pissed off if it was just like
uh an illusion over the atmosphere right
the sky uh they'd just be like oh you're
just confused a lot of people um
i think there was more things happening
that like pissed them off but it uh i
wonder if like by doing this what konsha
did is he wasn't moving this the heavens
he wasn't affecting the heavens he was
affecting earth and encapsulating earth
within kind of a pocket reality
extracting it from the reality it was on
and now putting this earth in a bubble
that
is in a rewound universe
so i know that's confusing but imagine
like uh you know the theory of
relativity it's not the heavens that
moved it's earth that kind of like wanda
transporting west view outside of new
jersey in encapsulating it into its own
kind of pocket reality that's what he
did so
within that pocket reality things can
get warped the nature of reality it
worked but as we saw in westview things
that entered that pocket reality they
came back out warped like the drone
changed into a helicopter um uh monica's
clothes changed so i think like still
within that pocket reality the nature of
reality it's still
corporeal and real until like the spell
gets broken and maybe that's what they
did by turning them into a new shopkee i
just think it's possible that like what
we're seeing is a kind of a a
multiversal effect maybe that's what the
clue of the american chavez star was it
looks like the same kind of shape as the
patch that's on the back of her jacket
and the portals that she kicks in
maybe multiverse of madness will give us
more context maybe this is just another
example of reality being distorted in
specific ways and then the illuminati's
gonna be real pissed off about this and
they're like we got one of our buddies
susan on the internet and he told us
what you did
and we ain't too happy about that
uh anyway there's just a lot of there's
a lot of crazy ways to look at this and
yeah i think that you're going to be
honest
like to me that's the most interesting
for sure yeah like you know kanji was a
god and like he has so many powers and
like gods can do so many different
things so like i could definitely see a
pocket reality situation going in like
either way i would love if you know if
thor and like came back to earth he's
like what happened to the planet because
he was off the planet before whatever
country did so like
[Laughter]
i wonder what's gonna happen there
me too i i have a ton of questions now
my hope is that the show doesn't just
like leave this unaddressed because it
seems like that's how the eternals left
things it's just like look there's just
a big dead celestial in the indian ocean
it's possible i think ultimately all
these things are just like examples of
like things just getting so messed up on
the mcu earth that
we gotta reboot it wanda's gotta warm
reality and reboot so we just need to
just like unplug the computer and
restart the simulation that's the only
way
there's too many weird settings that we
put on this too many notifications hey
man yeah spells multiversal badges
[Laughter]
i want to talk about the any ad nt so
this is any ad why doesn't the iniad
intervene with the affairs of mankind
like why did they make that choice
to step up well um it's because our
breath stank eric just kidding no
well true
it's true no it's uh well they say that
it's because
we stopped caring about the gods and we
then humanity stopped worshiping the the
egyptian idiot and so they were like hey
you know what they don't care about us
we don't care about them we're gonna go
it's like when you stop believing it's
santa he stops bringing me presents
exactly um so like they're off in this
place that um mark call well konju calls
the overvoid which is the celestial
heliopolis in the comics and this is
where all the egyptian gods live off in
their own separate dimension and so you
know i think that you know this iniad
because you know there's no belief there
from a lot of like a lot of people they
were just like you know what they seem
like they want to be the gods of
themselves well let's just let's let
them do that and conscious like no um we
have to protect these people and because
i care about them in my weird way so
like i'm going to avenge people that
hurt them and so you know it's conscious
even though he's a jerk he's the nicest
egyptian god that we have the most
compassionate which is weird um in the
mcu hot tour hot tour is pretty
compassionate yes outdoor ah
i don't trust hobbies
i think it's all a mixed bag i think
they're all pretty uh amoral at the end
of the day this is true but hattor ah
that god i don't trust that guy i like
yahtzeel her avatar nice lady
yeah yeah um but the ex of uh i think
you're right you're right it wasn't hot
hot had left the building it was her
avatar who took pity good point yes
yeah
i don't trust her at all
oh as you shouldn't um so but why uh
what other gods do you think the iniad
might have transformed into ushabtes hmm
i see i don't know
are this are these all that is left of
the active egyptian gods because there
are way more egyptian gods than you've
just been thought yeah all of them been
turned into obstacles that is
interesting because like that makes me
think about like what if there's some
corruption in this council of gods and
like they're just over
arresting people you know and like and
turning them into shopties and that
that's really interesting i wonder what
happened to them yeah i mean it seems
like there was some kind of power grab
at some point maybe they got paranoid by
uh by like
you know amit being betrayed or
something like that and they're like we
gotta just like
we gotta
circle the wagons a bit
yeah and like maybe like they were as
mad about not interfering with humanity
as kanchi was and that they were maybe
there was like this huge war it was like
all right you guys didn't want to listen
to us so you guys are arrested and can't
you you could be like that if you don't
you don't listen he's like i'm just
gonna i'm gonna behave
sort of
i don't know i think i think kang
freaked him out i think
he could continue oh yeah i i i'm
praying for a canned cameo like where is
cake come on man i know everyone's like
you just want the fist though to be nbc
and i'm like no i want kang to be in
everything yeah did you not watch our
little
show i have moved on from a festive
friend
i'm in the kang gang okay hey
we want gang kang's the cooler character
we watch out of the majors to be in
everything that guy's so good
and he's looking good you saw those set
photos
man's too jacked
all right well we'll leave it there for
this
episode of inside marvel aka the episode
that will get me cancelled
it was gonna happen it was gonna happen
but you know i'm glad that i that i uh
got to share this with you and t it's no
no
listen everybody we are going to try to
address a moon knight in the most
tactful the way that we can did is a
very serious thing and both us and
marvel studios are trying to tackle this
in a very um smart way so we're not
trying to make wild theories based on
did because it's fun we're just trying
to just look at the factors that we have
on the show which are did and mystical
elements and just seeing what marvel
studios is going to do with that because
they can do so much with that
and you know it's going to be in a very
um smart and intelligent way so
is he's trying to answer the questions
you guys are asking us too and i just
want to exactly exactly like i never
believe in just like i had a crazy
theory on this and no one asked me about
this so i'm just gonna like make you all
listen to it honestly like everything i
do here in new rockstars it's because
like a ton of people are tweeting me
asking this stuff exactly
we're trying to answer that question bro
it's the speculation nation we are
trying to figure out the answers to
questions that you guys have that's our
job and we're trying to do it in the
best way that we can so and we
appreciate how the vast majority of you
seem to be with us on that journey and
we appreciate all your support for
everything that we do here uh and we're
here for you so we'll be back next week
i can't wait to see a tease breakdown of
this episode
it was a fun one yeah um so don't forget
to check out our great merch options new
rockstarsmerch.com the best way to
support what we do here you can follow
me at ea boss follow mt master team and
subscribe to inside marvel wherever get
your podcast and of course subscribe to
the channel here on youtube thank you so
much for watching and we'll see you next
time later skaters layers
you